this video is sponsored by audible a
moderator stands in front of six people
sitting at a table in a mid-sized
white-walled room the rules of the game
are fairly simple
he says you take turns rolling two
virtual dice the combined number you
roll is how many spaces you move forward
on the game map he points to a map on a
large screen at the front of the room
which is also displayed on much smaller
tablet screens in front of each player
along the map there are spaces the
moderator goes on with most of them are
empty spaces that you just travel across
some spaces however are called fortune
spaces each of which has a number on it
land on one and your player moves
forward the number you initially rolled
times the number labeled on the space
for example if you roll an eight and
land on a fortune space labeled with the
number two you move forward sixteen more
spaces there are also spaces called
regressive spaces these also have a
number land on one of these though you
go backwards the number you rolled times
the number label lastly there are reward
spaces the number labeled on these
signifies point values land on one of
them moving forward earned the number of
points labeled land on one of them
moving backwards off of regressive space
lose the number of points the further
forward you go in the map the larger the
point values get got it the players nod
their heads in agreement the moderator
instructs each player to press start on
their screens each players icon that
appears on the game map player one
Charles to Sarah
three John four Jess five Christa six
Sam each icon is in a different starting
location on the map giving each player
advantages and disadvantages according
to their arbitrary player numbers
charles starts at the front ok now the
most important part how do you win the
moderator goes on with the player with
the most points by the end wins
obviously but the catch is the game only
ends once everybody decides to stop
playing meaning the game goes on as long
as you continue to play the map is
infinite you can eat sleep and use the
restroom during designated times but
otherwise you must be here playing the
game at any point you may choose to opt
out of the game and leave at which point
however you lose you can all choose
unanimously to stop at the same time but
the person with the most points at that
time still wins if however you do not
all choose to stop at the same time the
last person who is still here playing
can play as long as they'd like until
they've reached how
many points they need to win the
moderator pauses and looks at the group
of players questions he asks the players
look back at the moderator then around
at each other they say nothing good
let's begin concludes the moderator the
moderator instructs Charles to go first
he presses the roll button on a screen
and Rosa four-on-one dice and a three on
the other his icon moves forward 7
spaces the rest of the players in order
front to back follow suit
they go around and around each player
rolling the dice getting excited about
each collection of points and upset
about each loss the fortune reward and
regressive spaces are spread out just
enough to be uncertain and infrequent
but just close enough to keep each
player engaged in on the edge of their
seat hopeful that at any moment they'll
jump a massive distance and take the
lead and fearful that at any moment
they'll fall back a massive distance and
lose everything by the end of the first
day Charles is in the lead with the most
points then John Sarah Jess Sam and last
Christa two more days go by all the
players are still in they are all bored
and anxious in a constant back-and-forth
between wanting to leave and stay
resulting in an inertia that keeps them
all in the game inevitably tensions have
increased with time as players have
begun to more tightly associate their
identities with their positions in the
game Charles has been in the lead since
the start of the game and is holding it
over everyone's head emitting a sense of
superiority and importance and eliciting
spite from all the other players as they
grow increasingly annoyed by him yet
desirous of being in his position it's
John's turn heroes a three and a two he
moves forward five spaces it's an 80 X
fortune space moves forward another 400
spaces and collects 16200 points putting
him in first he boasts with pretension
and animosity towards the other players
especially Charles Charles tells him to
shut up and sit down
John moves towards Charles and asks or
what Charles jolts up and gets in John's
face and says nothing
John is suddenly frightened not
expecting Charles's reaction John puts
all his effort towards not showing his
fear outwardly and pushes Charles away
from him Charles seizes the opportunity
to release his pent-up energy and
boredom and lunges at John taking him to
the floor pinning him to the ground in a
position that partly chokes John the
moderator watches as they
only after John loosens out of Charles
grip and throws several punches does the
moderator finally break it up
after being separated and resettled John
and Charles returned to their seats
boiling with tension nerves and anger at
this point Krista announces her
disinterest in the game and her
intention to leave she's had more than
enough Charles John and Jess ridicule
her as she leaves Sam and Sarah observed
quietly they also consider leaving but
fear being ridiculed and feeling like
quitters they decide to stay and see it
through
after all how long could a game like
this even go on the game goes on for an
absurd length of more time it's the
seventh day now Sam is now left after
suddenly and strangely realizing on the
fifth day that he no longer had any idea
why they were even playing in the first
place he doesn't announce this
realization though and just quietly gets
up and leaves him and Krista leaving has
only reinforced the remaining players
justification for staying now that the
end game appears that much closer it's
not about winning the game anymore but
merely about outlasting the other
players and proving their superiority of
endurance and ability the game is
completely random yet somehow all the
remaining players have made it about
themselves on the eighth day Charles is
back in the lead
John is in second then Sarah and last
Jess it's Charles's turn he rolls a 6
and a 1 he moves forward 7 spaces on to
a regressive space labeled
100x he then moves backwards 700 spaces
and loses 900,000 218 points moving him
from first place to last place in a
single roll wait hold on Charles erupts
- the moderator I've been in the lead
for almost the whole game and just like
that I'm last now how was that fair it's
random it's been like that the whole
time replies the moderator yeah well I
think we should change the rules like if
you're in the lead long enough you
should get extra points or if you're in
last long enough you should lose points
or something like that argues Charles
you cannot change the rules of the game
who applies the moderator Charles pounds
his tablet on the table but what's the
point of the stupid game anyway he
shouts at the moderator to
replies the moderator yeah but when what
asks Charles the game the moderator
matter-of-factly replies what do you
mean the game I mean what do you win by
winning the game Charles goes on with
nothing replies the moderator the whole
group pauses for a moment as if suddenly
stricken with the collective realization
that they had been duped into spending
all this time playing a game without
even knowing why or how they got there
one by one all the players decide to opt
out they get up from their seats and
walk towards the exit of the room just
as they are about to reach the exit door
John stops and says actually I mean I
made it this far and I'm in the lead now
I'm not losing if everyone's just
leaving he laughs to himself turns
around and goes back to his seat to win
the other players stop and watch him if
you're not leaving neither am i says
Charles he then returns to his seat then
Jess then Sarah John now back at a seat
with the rest of the group presses the
roll button for his turn a large screen
that has John Charles Jess Sarah and the
moderator on it glitches into
nothingness an individual named steely
who ordered the stop sits at the head of
a meeting room table with the group of
software engineers all dressed in
similar white uniforms who was lead
coder on this one steely asks the group
there's a brief pause in the room and
then an engineer nervously speaks out
that was me sir how the hell'd you fix
the realization problem for for the
personality types steely asks I just
adjusted their incentive algorithms to
skew more towards self-esteem rather
than rationality answers the engineer
theoretically when we extrapolate them
out across billions of character
iterations in the full simulation they
should just keep playing forever they
just want to win brilliant
steely exclaims thank you sir replies
the engineer
let's try skewing Kristen Sam's
algorithms more to keep them in a little
longer and try to make the whole thing a
little less bleak especially if they're
just gonna keep playing forever it's
entertaining but you know we need
consumers to feel good nobody wants to
buy simulated world where everyone is
just willing to suffer for no reason the
engineer at the front of the room makes
a couple adjustments on a small tablet
screen according to steelies instruction
he adjusts Christa and Sam's algorithms
and then applies a new variable to the
whole group the main display screen
loads up again the gay moderator appears
in six players render in two seats at a
table
mid sized white walled room the
moderator looks at them and says the
rules of the game are fairly simple you
take turns rolling two virtual dice the
combined number you roll is how many
spaces you move forward on the game map
[Music]
this video was sponsored by audible
honorable has the world's largest
collection of audio books with titles
from nearly all genres professionally
voiced by actors authors and speakers
like the on gram Mel Robbins and Wil
Wheaton to name a couple audible has
bestsellers classic fiction philosophy
business self-improvement memoirs and
more covering just about any area of
interest
currently audible members get more than
ever with three titles every month
including one audiobook and two audible
originals that you can't hear anywhere
else
audible members also get free access to
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
and Washington Post as well as unlimited
access to more than a hundred audio
guided fitness and meditation programs
all delivered daily through audible zap
whether it's during a commute at the gym
on a walk or anywhere the audible app
can be accessed from any device picking
up right where you left off making audio
learning and entertainment easy and
convenient audible also offers free
audio book exchanges credits that you
can roll over for a year and a library
that you can keep forever even if you
cancel visit audible.com slash pursuit
of wonder or text pursuit of wonder to
five zero zero five zero zero and you
can start listening today with a 30 day
trial and your first audiobook plus two
audible originals for free if you're
interested in science fiction they have
plenty of great titles including
classics by Aldous Huxley Isaac Asimov
Frank Herbert Kurt Vonnegut and many
more one title in particular worth
checking out if you have not already its
player piano by Kurt Vonnegut player
piano is Vonnegut's first novel written
in 1952
however the ideas in topics in the novel
are arguably more relevant now than ever
said in a dystopian like future Vonnegut
explores the relationship between
technological automation economic
efficiency and the human need for a
sense of purpose the story is fighting
Lee close to reality now with the
implications of AI and job automation
only becoming more relevant making the
novel a fascinating time cap
of humanity's entrance into modern
technology again if you're interested
visit audible.com slash pursuit of
wonder or text pursuit of wonders at
five zero zero five zero zero and
explore all the stories and information
audible has to offer
[Music]